Yeah, yeah, you're gonna feast on this one. Conceptuality is something other than itself.
There's been a change in the image of thought. That's what it is. That's what it is. That's what
it is. The internal structure of book as soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced
from the subject. Well, if this is, we started, like, in the in the spring, I think, or the spring, or
early summer, it was because when you were up in Pennsylvania, right? Yeah, yeah, it was. Right? It was
basically simultaneous. Yeah, podcast and Cara. We fucking missed our anniversary. We missed our
three-year anniversary. Yeah, yeah. Well, the other thing is, is there's an obvious correlation between
this podcast and your relationship. There's no question about that. Yeah, like, if you want to have
a long, healthy, joyous relationship with Cara, you know, you have to commit yourself to the podcast.
I was thinking of phrasing it. I was thinking of phrasing it the other way.
If you need to have, if you want to have a good podcast, you're gonna have to commit to your life.
You need a girlfriend. Yeah, yeah. One necessitates the other, for sure. I mean, they're clearly linked.
So they're, and I'd say that's causal and not merely a correlation, and we wouldn't have the artwork.
We wouldn't have the art. Well, let's strike on that. Let's strike on that segue. By the way, between
causation and correlation, I'm just saying, like, you know, the number of segues, you know, they're, they're
not an infinite number of them. That's a decent one. I like it. Oh, we should do the introduction.
Oh, yeah, introduction. Give us an intro. What are we doing? We're doing book three. I forgot. What do we do
on the introduction? No, no, no. We got to introduce ourselves though, guys. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. But I
have a new title. I don't know if I've announced my new position. I am now a visiting assistant professor
of writing and communication at oberland college nathan deprosby yeah nate
Oh, my God, we've got to do a totally new, we have to do a completely new thing now. All right, John,
introduce yourself. I don't have anything new. I'm John. I'm still John. I haven't done jack shit. I
haven't gotten promoted. I haven't published anything. I just didn't like, I just bought, I just bought a book
with, uh, with a chapter of yours in it, maybe. I don't know when it was, but a signification, yeah.
That came out? What? That came out, I think, last year or something. I don't know. Oh, okay. Oh, that's still
that's, that's what's the time frame we're talking about? I had an article come out and nobody cares.
Not even me.
This is book three of the of the Gay Science. And yes, we'll spend at least one episode or two episodes
on this. Maybe we're gonna spend at least two episodes on this. This, I forgot about the beginning
of book three, the shadows of God stuff. It's just like so many amazing aphorisms here. I mean, this is
and I even used to teach, like, at an undergrad level, I used to teach the first, like, six or eight pages
of of this in terms of the shadow, the shadows of God, right? Like, here's very teachable are the
shadows of God, and they're so teachable. Yep. Yeah, you said this one started off with a bang. I just wrote
a little heart next to it. But this is, yeah, the very first aphorism of book three, new battles as aphorism
108. After Buddha was dead, they still showed his shadow in a cave for centuries, a tremendous gruesome
shadow. God is dead, but given the way people are, there may still for millennia be caves in which
they show his shadow, and we, we must still defeat his shadow as well. We had this conversation last time
about the, like, Nietzsche is perceived as not as a systemic philosopher as, like, there's just sort of
like a random assortment of relatively themed, like, maybe there are some themes that run through, but
assortment of aphorisms. But this is just so clear. It's like that claim about the shadows of God. Like,
we, like, we might kill God, but there are still sort of like, there are still the logics of God, of the, of
the, uh, of the deity. That's still theological logics that play itself out in other places trans. Yeah, right.
Um, and then like the next, you know how many of our aphorisms are just like basically listing out what
are those shadows of God? You know, science, logic, morality, cause and effect, substance, yeah, substance
that there are things, yeah, metaphysics. Yeah, it's quite systematic, I would say this section at least.
I only got through probably like a fourth of it or like a third of it, so I don't know. Did you guys
read? You guys have already read the whole thing before, but um, I didn't. Just as a side note, I didn't even
know this is where the first, like, proclamation of God is dead. I didn't know that's where it appears.
I had cited it even casually, like Nietzsche's famous proclamation, you know, and I didn't even know
this this is where it first appears. Well, it also appears later in the book, so the, the one in book
Three the the other 25. Yeah, and the madman one is tends to be like the more famous one for and I don't
really know why. Like, when when people cite Nietzsche on saying God is dead, they they tend to quote the
madman section rather than this one. Yeah, um, but yeah, it is the first first proclamation of God is
dead. We'll talk about like reading something without having read it. It's like I've read so much Nietzsche
that I felt like I'd already seen that passage, but I actually hadn't until today. Yeah, which is funny
and it's also so faint. I mean, it's just so famous, right? Like, it's of course. Yeah, um, so I so I that's
when you sent that I thought I I remember thinking that when you sent that text I was like, oh, he hasn't
read this before. Nope, uh, like he just had that experience like, whoa, wait, this is
and this one seems more celebratory. I mean, it's the interesting thing of course is that like
everybody I mean, we'll get to this probably next time, but like everybody takes the God is dead to
be this proclamation of atheism and it's actually a critique. It's a critique of atheism, you know, right?
and it's it's really clear in the madman passage, like it's really clear that it's a critique of
atheism, but like yeah this this one sounds more like a critique of religion. Like we we still have
to vanquish his shadow, like right, you know, we're we're on a mission to get rid of those uh shadows
of God so it's this one fits more with the usual reading of yeah Nietzsche says that God is dead well
so how does it function as a critique of atheism? Is it that even atheism kind of imports atheists don't
realize what they've done? They don't realize the they don't realize the implications of all the
shadows. Okay, yeah, they also don't understand they also don't understand the um the subtle ways in
which the logic of of God of the the theological function still operates within all of their
within atheism, right? So like God within the specifically like yeah exactly God like the
God function the God term still operates in science and logic and all of these other places which you
know I mean I think at one I think this is maybe just in the in 109 where it's like you have we have
to de-deify nature. Like basically getting rid of battling the shadows of God is the de-deification of
nature, metaphysics, logic, all of these sorts of things. But this is also, you know, you read here I mean this
is it's like he really hasn't gotten at least to me he really hasn't gotten to will to power
as strongly enough in his thinking at this point because you know he's basically like
we we shouldn't call nature an organ, you know, let's not treat it as an organism let's not treat
it as a machine. Let's not treat it and what he's sort of missing there is like there's no alternative
right? There's no there's no option. Like the the only way to go is to anthropomorphize, right? And
that's the the only option. It's not there isn't a real uh how nature really works apart from the
appropriative move of how we describe how nature works. Yeah, and so he you know so in that sense it's
like this this ends up being much more of a um much more of a kind of a certain kind of pluralism as
opposed to a power, you know, just saying like no actually like the mechanistic description
right just as good as any other description because it's no because the description is not a question
of adequate representation of reality. It is it is an appropriation it is an interpretation
of nature right it meaning an appropriation and a subduing like that's what it is
we're going to talk about the God is dead stuff it kind of feels appropriate for today to focus
between 108 and 125. 125 is the madman and 108 is the introduction of the death of God sort of like
I feel like everything in between it is very sort of explicitly in reference to that and I found it
interesting this time reading it that because I hadn't thought about it this way but the the madman
almost bookends the death of God stuff you know it is and then I mean it's not like we leave that
behind afterwards but it definitely there definitely is a bit of a bit of a shift after that 125 mark and
it's just it was interesting to me to think about like why that one ends there why that one comes so late
in in that sort of progression of aphorisms um and the other thing too though John you're talking about
the will to power stuff and how will to power doesn't really seem to emerge much as a as a concept or a
force here but on the one hand I agree with you because there's even that whole aphorism on the sort of
the um the ephemeral nature of the will um I think that's this is 127 actually actually that's called the
after effects of the oldest religiosity. Yeah, he's taking he's taking on Schopenhauer there
but it seems very clear he's talking about will in the way that we typically think of it like
the will which is um uh a a faculty or power of the subject and he's very clearly not talking about will
To power there but he does he doesn't use the language of will to power but he definitely
attends to the sort of the um the orientation or the pull to something of expressing power the expression
of power whatever it is and now it just might be like you know uh various configurations of forces
express various powers and they let's not talk about them as being errors or illnesses or how there are
many healths there are many expressions of power so like i think it's i think it's there but i think that
that dynamic the the sort of vacillation between a will and will to power or what you were talking
about the sort of um the inventiveness of something and not thinking about you know like you were talking
about 109 and thinking about um uh not thinking about the world as an organism as a machine as a but so
it's yeah but like for instance these places where he says like judge from the point of view of our
reason unsuccessful attempts this is in 109 um unsuccessful attempts are by all odds the rule
the exceptions are not the secret aim and the whole musical box repeats eternally its tune uh which may
never be called a melody and ultimately even the phrase unsuccessful attempt is too anthropomorphic
and reproachful um but how can we reproach or praise the universe let us be aware of attributing
let us be aware of you know and there's a continuous so let us be aware of attributing and that to me is
like well why should we be aware i mean one it's it's a different thing to say there are implications
of thinking of nature as an organism and there are implications to thinking of nature as a mechanism
right like and you can follow this out but it's not like we're not being fair we're not being just
or we're being well what's the phrase there too anthropomorphic and it's like well given will to power
you you can't be less anthropomorphic right there's not a less anthropomorphic way of thinking about
nature so you know but that doesn't make them the same so that's fine like there are differences
between a mechanistic worldview and a vitalistic worldview or you know whatever your your things
are um but there's no right one and you know so the whole let us be aware is on the one hand an
important caution in the sense of saying there are implications behind any particular metaphorics
that one picks up but on the other hand seems a little too like we're not getting it right right
there's still there's still a sense in a couple of these sections that like we could demystify
this process like there could be an end result there's a there's a secret that we're missing
and i think less anthropomorphic way of doing this right right which and i i feel like there's like
two niches then in that sense because there's there's moments where he does that and then of course there's
later in his uh articulations of the will to power where he says like you're saying there's nothing
other than appropriation there are different valences of human appropriation but there is no outside
of that well i don't know that he's not saying it here because i mean at the the last couple of
sentences of 109 you know and the motif here is be aware of this be aware of that be aware of that and
he never like gets you to and here's the right thing it says constantly be aware and then you know
the last couple of sentences but when will we when will we will we be done with our caution and care
when will all these shadows of god no longer darken us when will we have completely deified nature when
may we begin to naturalize humanity with a pure newly discovered newly redeemed nature okay there's
just a series of questions and he doesn't offer up you know a an answer to that but there is a sort
of sense of like that's you know be aware of this be aware stuff too that there's no real ending to
this this be aware stuff so it's not like you know you were previously working in error and then now
you're going to get to the real oh i see how you're i see how you're doing it yeah right and it's more
like well look being aware is just one other sort of dimension of this thing and it's not going to
get you to a state of not being aware in the same way that we've talked about a lot in this podcast of
like a problem uh or a problematic as being something that only um produces responses to it
and not something that you just simply solve and then get rid of yeah i don't i don't think this is
like a i'm not saying this is a naive version of Nietzsche it just feels like he's a little bit on a balance
beam or something between the two orientations or between various interpretations of this problematic
where it feels like like even just in the terminology where um he would later he would say will to power
he says here lust for power right even just that kind of like preliminary terminology for the problem
tells me that he hasn't quite articulated the full complexity of this problematic i think at least
like it at least that's what it seems like um in a few of these early sections or maybe it's just a
sort of polemical tone, right? Like, I mean, because, I mean, the next, the origin of knowledge stuff, the
next stuff is like, look, we, you know, um, they're just a bunch of things that people, uh, have believed in
that, like, on their own, were, uh, um, so included such erroneous articles of faith which were
continually inherited until it became almost part of the basic endowment of the species that there are
equal things, that there are things, substances, bodies, that a thing is what it appears to be, that our will
is free, that what is good for me is only good, like, you know, they're these fundamental things that it
was only very late that people began to be like, you know, uh, is that true? It was only that such
propositions were denied and doubted. It is only very, very late then that truth emerged as the weakest
form of knowledge, which is doubting these intuitive certainties, that there are such, there is such a
thing as equality, right? Um, it seemed that one was unable to live with it. Our organism was prepared for
the opposite, all of its higher functions, sense perceptions, that every kind of sense say here to me this is a
much more resonant with like, yeah, this is a, it's, you know, there was a type of life at one point that
couldn't endure truth, um, and because it was, you know, it just needed it, needed the, the sort of lies of
that there are things, substances, bodies, right? That, that, that there is equality, that there, you know
it, we, we just needed those as intuitive, and that's where to me the will to power is just a symptom of
different types of life, um, right? And these types of life change, so we are now the inheritors of a
different, uh, uh, tradition where we can ask, uh, what, like, what the function of equality is in mathematics
and be like, does that even make sense? Does anything ever equal anything else? Um, as a question now, which you
couldn't do, um, a different but as the as the weakest form of knowledge, right? And and because he's gonna
sort of emphasize the value to go back to our question about, like, you know, what does rhetoric have
to do with this, you know, the the next line here is, um, thus the strength of knowledge lies not in its
degree of truth but in its age, its embeddedness, its character as a condition of life, and so much of this and
this goes on in the next few of them is like it's not about whether it's true or not, it's about what
it does. How does it intersect the the human being? How does it intersect other the other and that's
the other kinds of forces and that's totally will to power yeah yeah what what kind of life does it
facilitate? Yeah, where life and knowledge are at odds there's never really a fight right like right
yeah life wins life is because knowledge is a form of it so what i like how he turns to the
laics as well here and it's like, you know, they're this interesting case study wherein they start to
sort of almost impose truth onto life, right? They don't hang out all that long, like, they're like
you know, anytime there's a problem, you know, it they they kind of get the uh the blunt end of the
the hammer. Well or they just it just recognizes it's a different form of life
you know, but look to the bottom of 110 there, um, uh, sorry, yeah, the bottom of 110, thus knowledge became
a part of life and as life a continually growing power until finally knowledge and the ancient basic
errors struck against each other both as life both as power both in the same person, right? The thinker
that is now the being in whom the drive to truth and for those life-preserving errors are fighting their
first battle after the drive to truth has proven itself to be a life-preserving power too
in relation to the significance of this battle everything else is a matter of indifference
the ultimate question about the condition of life is posed here and the first attempt is made here
to answer the question through experiment to what extent can truth stand to be incorporated that is
the question that is the experiment so i mean that resonates totally with the truth totally with the
power stuff i absolutely agree yeah i mean and that's so effectively that's what we are right like
we are the collision of life-preserving errors and life-preserving truths um yeah and having to
live them both. Well, they're at, because those two things aren't even the same, right? So life
preserving errors, right? Which become dogmas and then sort of configured as truth now suddenly truth
emerges as a thing to care about, right? Only through these other sort of like rhetorical configurations
that he's calling sort of errors here. Now suddenly this drive toward truth which again differentiated
itself and emerged out emerged out of those errors and differentiated itself from now they develop a
new sort of coordination with each other and something else is possible the experimentation of what this
newly relatively newly formed drive toward truth does and how it sort of interacts with these sort of like
older more established developed instincts that are preserving to life that we used to call truths or we still
Sometimes right, but now I feel like I mean I I feel like the the the experiment is now something more like
we can create whatever kind of world we want to, yeah yeah, make, right, like that, uh, um, so now we realize
that, right, like, so now, like, like, let's let's get to making something at least different, and you know, it feels like
like a historical argument at like at a certain level where it's like only only just now is this is this
being enabled, like the desire for truth has enabled both the proliferation of knowledge-making practices to
the point where it's any any kind of practice, it's it's there are infinite possibilities at this point for the
production of truth, and then the flip side of that is that that development in quotes has also unraveled
the concept of truth and knowledge to the point of it being kind of incoherent, so you have to somehow
resolve or negotiate those those um those tensions right? Well, the genealogical orientation in
these aphorisms is really really strong, and this is before he writes the genealogy of morality
but there's, I mean, like, The Gay Science was written in two parts, and I I don't know how much of the
genealogy of um morality is sort of interested, like, spliced within that
I kind of realized that um aphorism 111 John is where you get your caveman and saber-toothed tiger
story, yeah yeah, treating as equal. Oh, can I, did I ever tell you, did I ever tell you, I was reading
a novel not long ago, my god, I wish I had written it down, and or maybe I was listening to the novel
and they used that exam they used that saber-toothed tiger thing and I'm like I know I made that up like
I know this is one of those things that I am certain because I remember making that up like 20
something years ago, like I didn't read it anywhere, like I I came up with that example and I've refined
it over the years, the saber-toothed tiger example, and I read it in a novel, like some novelist, and I'm
like now it wasn't exactly the same and there was a little bit of a variation but I was like
what the fuck, turns out that was a former student, is it a former student or a former student has said
something to this person or something like I don't know, and it was a recent novelist, like it's someone
who's alive and who you know, like that's imaginable because that is one of those things it's like the
opposite of my productive reading story where it's like I was sure that I did not make that term up
and I was going to get accused of plagiarizing and I couldn't find it anywhere whereas this is like
I'm sure I made up the saber-toothed tiger story but then you then you read things like this and you're
like well there it's right there it's kind of right there I mean it's not a tiger or certainly
not a saber-toothed tiger but in this example it's really like in this novel whatever this novel is
it's actually a freaking saber-toothed tiger like and I'm really that's why yeah I I wish that I had
marked it's one of those like maybe I was out on the water or something when I heard it and you know
I don't remember you gotta reach out I would love to know who that is yeah because I've used that story
a lot I've always credited it to you but I've like it doesn't matter like I don't even care I don't
care in terms of I mean it's not even the the kind of thing it's just like I am sure that I came up
with that because I remember trying to come up with an example to teach truth and lies and I was like I
got to come up with a concrete example of the same and the equal and what lives and what dies and so I
mean you know and then again like like I said I've refined it over the years and it's now it's it's a
a better one now but like I know I didn't read that anywhere because I remember yes trying to
come up with it and then to read the question in the book that you read do they come home and write
a book about it no they don't do they come so and it's not and it's not exactly the same point they're
not making the exact same point it's a variation but I was like fuck and it certainly wasn't a book
that was out 25 years ago it's like yeah something in the last it's like a sci-fi book in the last
five years no joke do you want to quickly do you want to quickly recite your version for our
listeners in case I don't I don't think we have that on wax it might be nice to have the we don't
have it on I think we yeah yeah we we did that one did we do it before I think we did it in one
episode it's worth doing it again did we do the truth and lie did we do truth and lies we didn't do
truth and lies but I think it kind of just popped up at some point but yeah but this is that's the
other thing about 111 here is that feels like um well it's not a proto version of truth and lies
because he wrote truth and lies way earlier but it feels like a a is more sort of like almost like
a bit of a refinement on it a little bit more of a a a more pointed uh version of what he's talking
about there and in the few ones because he's talking about like you know this drive to truth
and where does it come from and how does it sort of evolve and he's doing this genealogical take on
it right but um but no yeah, John, do you want to do you want to do your uh yeah i mean the whole
point is is the the unethical quality of our perception that we treat we perceive as equal
things which are merely similar and as Nietzsche says in truth and lies where he's like in other
words we perceive as equal things that are not equal right right yeah that's that's just what it means to
be a human is to unethically perceive in that sense and so yeah the example that i was given is like
one day there's three cavemen walking down a uh walking down the road and uh um this there's this
big furry thing on a rock in the distance and it growls and it jumps down and it kills one of them
the other two guys run away and the next day the other two guys are walking along a different path
somewhere else and there's something on a different rock that's like not exactly the same size whatever
but it sort of growls and so two two and they have two different reactions uh guy number one we'll call
him Fred. Fred's like well that thing up there is not exactly the same as the thing that we saw
yesterday that ate our friend but it's similar enough that i'm going to treat it as as if um it's the same
thing and so i'm going to run away um whereas the other guy uh Mike Mike goes like ah that thing is
its own unique absolutely individual uh singular experience and so therefore i can't make any assumptions
about it and so i'm not going to do anything any any differently so what happens well the saber-toothed
tiger jumps down and eats Mike whereas Fred lee you know runs away goes home and he writes a book
and the book is entitled The Truth of Saber-Toothed Tigers so the epistemological question is um which
one of them is more truthful Fred or Mike so and that's i mean and that's where i leave it like
which one is more honest which one is more truthful the one who sees the singularity of something or the
one who subsumes it in the lie and produces the notion of truth because let's be honest that book
will circulate around you know other cavemen will their lives will be saved because they can now read
this book and and sort of identify the characteristics of the saber-toothed tiger despite the fact that we are
treating as similar that or we are treating as the same that which is merely similar not also tiger attack
yeah and that all you know that as that that truth uh dogmatically circulates then that means that
anything subsumed by the category of saber-toothed tiger is going to get articulated as such whether
they would act in that way or not this is more like yeah the production of the thing called saber-toothed
tiger is getting made by the guy who writes the book called The Truth of Saber-Toothed Tigers and you
could map that story onto an array of Nietzsche's concepts metaphor uh artistic and rational man you'd
say uh Fred was rational man right because he wrote the book and made the productive lie
well it's just that his particular way of his particular way of perceiving survives i mean it's that
simple right and whereas the way of perceiving that sees everything as totally unique and doesn't
doesn't see in things order or doesn't produce through their perception sameness
right when there isn't sameness in the thing so the perception that doesn't produce sameness dies
right it gets killed um it it can't live right and so it's not a question of it being good bad right
wrong it just dies so the perception the type of perception that survives is the one that
treats as you know that that treats as equal things that are not equal right you know right that's that's
the more successful survival strategy so that's the means of perception that continues and so i mean
that's where you know and he gets into all the like there's an extent to which we we allow our
concepts to play in certain registers like art right like what i mean this is what you know you always
i always say to students whenever it's like every single one of you loves to be lied to and they're all
like what the fuck are you talking about like do you like movies do you like reading you know like
novel like that's all it is all all that happens when you're watching a movie is you're being lied to
you're being tricked like that's the whole thing and you love it it's in it's it's called entertainment
it's we go to this thing right and so like that's the arena because it's safe we so we actually enjoy
lies i mean that's his claim and you know we actually enjoy it's part of what gives humans pleasure we
just don't want to die from it you know yeah so we like this i mean this one is just so incredibly
important for a variety of reasons i mean both i mean it's such a direct attack on the logic of
identity which is obviously you know the kernel of scientific philosophical theological like what's
called human knowledge is like epistemology is sort of like predicated even ontology sort of predicated on
The notion that X is identical to itself, and if you know, uh, um, and so, so important, I think sort of like
getting, like dipping your toes into something like there it are to lose or other sort of post-structuralists
who are in many ways I think directly or indirectly attend, like thinking about the problem of identity
the problem of being and sort of thinking a sort of post-structuralist notion of flux or becoming or
whatever else, but then it's also so I think incredibly important to thinking
the the role that rhetoric has here as well because the sort of the only constant here is
reconfiguration, reconfiguration, reconfiguration. Forget about the old baseline of thinking about
what is the essential permanent thing underneath that then just has a new surface on it's like no that
is, you know, the the the act of reconfiguration goes all the way down. it's why names are so important
yeah right so this is 111 it's called the origin of the logical what is the origin of logic in man's
head surely it arose out of the illogical the realm of which must have originally been immense but
innumerable beings drew inference in a way different from that in which we do now perished nonetheless they
might have been closer to the truth like michael who got eaten by the saber-toothed tiger right he for
instance who did not know how to find identity often enough both with regard to nourishment is this
plant healthy to eat is it not healthy to eat and to hostile animals is that a saber-toothed tiger is
it sufficiently you know similar or identical to the last thing that i saw that ate the first caveman
so that is he was assumed too slowly and was too cautious and subsumption which that's just the
language here of identification to identify something with something else so he who was not able to do
that had a slider or he who was able to do that had a slider probability of survival than he who in all
cases of similarity immediately guessed that they were identical the predominant i may have reversed
those on accident but the one that was more readily able to make the identifying move has a
better chance of survival it's also it just does it faster there right like it's like it just does
it instantly whereas yeah i mean that but that's exactly where he's going to be like look this this
this desire for sort of ah hang on a second let's think about that like i mean that impulse is a late
and recent impulse because that would have been a deadly response in for for most of human history
it's the speed of like okay that's the same as that i'm out of here right like hang on let's think
about that for a second like thinking is dangerous that's right that's all we do is be like yeah let's
think about that for a second it's like this this very behavior is very late like it it has to be very
late because you need to have you need to have that instant response i'm not eating yeah i'm running
Derrida could not have existed you know like you know probably prior to the 20th century because
he would have been eaten by something like even in the 1900s someone of Derrida's slow caution may
have still been let's think about whether or not we're thinking about whether or not we're thinking
about yeah oh my god there's no atheists or no theorists in a foxhole you know yeah yeah exactly
uh so so to continue similarly in order for the concept of substance so now we're talking about
metaphysics and logic so for the concept of substance to originate which is indispensable to
logic though nothing really corresponds to it in the strictest sense it was necessary that for a long
time changes in things not to be seen not to be perceived the beings who did not see things exactly
had a head start over those who saw everything in flux in other words yeah like you know mike again
like the one who's actually able to attend to the heracletian flux of all nature is perhaps in one
sense seeing things more truthfully because they're sort of their perception their sense perception is less
coarse and less clumsy uh but also from a survival standpoint way at a huge disadvantage because that's not
able to sort of more like ham-fistedly deal with the world around it confidently clearly distinctly finally
as such every great degree of caution in inferring every skeptical disposition is a great danger to
life no living being would have preserved would be preserved had not the opposite disposition to affirm
rather than suspend judgment to air and make things up rather than to wait and to agree rather than to not
deny to pass judgment rather than to be just have been bred to become extraordinarily strong
the course of logical thoughts and inferences in our brains totally or today corresponds to a process and battle of drives
that taken separately are all very illogical and
unjust we usually experience only the outcome of this battle that is how quickly and covertly this ancient mechanism runs its course in us
man back to that speed it's like this has to be instinct there can't be a thought pattern that leads who was your
Example Fred the caveman to say, ah, sufficiently, these are two different things, he would probably
like, that's the same motherfucking thing and didn't even think about it and peaced out, right? And then, and
and then maybe post hoc sort of like came up with a a lying of of justification for why he behaved that way as
he's writing the book but, you know, the battle that sort of led him to run away was so instantaneous
he only saw, you know, only the outcome of the battle is sort of like consciously perceptible to him
but now, but, you know, what changes is obviously like over time that this this uh desire for
um to suspend the judgment uh to wait to be skeptical uh to exhibit caution and making inferences
at a certain point that becomes beneficial for life as well, right? And that's that's the struggle that we
you know, in the end of the previous aphorism where it's like for the first time both of these things
are beneficial for for life and we are we are that struggle, like we're like, you know, that we are a
thinker is the person in whom those things, you know, but importantly differently so, right? It's not like
one has progressed beyond to the other one, it's just that oh yeah, this one was chugging a lawn and
doing a really good job and it had an off spurt and it was a little bit delusional about how it started
but it started to grow and do it its own thing as it started to be able to do some things that the first
set of impulses and desires we're not able to do and sort of can be productive for a different kind
of preserving life and but it's also if you just simply replaced one with the other, well
things are gonna yeah take a a serious nosedive pretty quickly. Yeah, well, i'm a little bit i'm
curious what you guys would think because my tendency when reading this is to to the the historical
argument becomes a little bit precarious but for me it's like it's some version of like once our basic
necessities have been met, once civilization is sufficiently sophisticated, now we can think
right it now thinking is no longer a danger to our well-being. I mean this is the this is the birth of
tragedy. The argument in the birth of tragedy is that in Socrates for the first time instinct
becomes not that which acts but that which prevents from acting. Yeah, that Socrates is an inversion
of you know the the usual way instinct is what makes you act whereas instinct is for Socrates like
hang on a second let's think about this, you know, right right yeah but also in a social organization
Socrates is a parasite right he just wanders around he's a creature of the city who wanders around and
pesters the instinct of everyone else right right and it's because Athens is capable of
of of allowing its parasites to to subsist and thrive, right? It's a sign of it. It's a sign of a great
health that's you know the yeah that well hell so it's like it depends on the perspective. Like from one
perspective it's like it's it's a sign of decadence and decline and then but at the same time what is
the call at the end for a musical Socrates but that is and he says he's like that's my Hegelian
book, right? Like that is or what it smells offensively yeah or something I think is the
the comment but that that that is the logic of of how that works. Instinct gets inverted in
that his sort of historical i mean he Socrates is obviously like a symptom right right
yeah but they do kill everybody not forget that that's another thing yeah yeah he's not it's not
around because he has it. Yeah, he hesitates a little bit too much around, you know, how you
makes everybody else hesitate and it's annoying as fuck, like thinking i mean, you know, you guys have
all read those dialogues. Imagine if you were one of those interlocutors you'd be like fuck you
yeah what the fuck there's a certain point there's a certain points like we could have i mean
people who listen to this might think we could do this endlessly we have to eat but uh but there's
a certain type of discourse we've all we've been involved in them that are just not fun. They're not
enjoyable and it's and there's socratic kinds of discourses like what we're doing now is not that
like this is a much more of a riffing uh relationship that we're we're involved in, not a kind of
dialectical in interrogation and specification. Now of course someone might say then you're not
really doing philosophy for which my response would be like i know i'm cool with that all right? Like
my field has actually always been rhetoric so you you got me i never said that um but nevertheless like
that's that still is you know disputation in that socratic sense is not just conversation
i remember in a previous episode i think on the Hegel tapes i brought up this point but
essentially that the social conditions economic conditions and nietzsche's time kind like not
necessarily in a cause and effect relationship but those are what enable his type of thinking that
Nietzsche could not have existed uh in ancient Greece or in the Middle Ages or whatever. Oh, yeah, there is
sort of a break, or there's a moment, modernity, you know, yeah, where you get all these these types of
thinking that that are deconstructionist in a way that wasn't available to thinking even a century prior
or 50 years prior maybe, but I remember you guys kind of reacting a little bit, um, against that thought.
Um, well, I mean, there's a historicism in Nietzsche that's that's powerful. Like, it's important. It's just
not a, it's certainly not a progressive historicism. No, um, it is an interpretive, you know, interpretation,
which is just a sort of take this thing from here and make it do something different over here, right?
So, um, but yeah, like the concept of necessity is very very strong in Nietzsche, like the the importance of
like not anything could happen at any time, that they're like everything that happens is is necessary.
Um, and or just sort of like go back to our conversation about, you know, the constructivism
and the rhizomes, like yeah, anything can happen, like Nietzsche could have come about at any point
if the sort of infrastructure was there. It's just it wasn't there, right, in other points in time, right, and
the and it didn't nothing progressed towards Nietzsche for sure, like right, you know, we could have progressed
like, you know, it could have, it's not like it's not linear at all. What's the one that's the doctrine of
the poisons in 113? So this is a perfect example of the type of thing where uh so this is uh well
you know you're on health right? Yeah, whereas like so many things have come together for scientific
thinking to originate, and all these necessary strengths had to be invented, practiced, and cultivated
separately. As long as they were separate, they frequently had an altogether different effect
than they do now that they are integrated into scientific thinking and hold each other in check.
Their effect was that of poisons. For example, the impulse to doubt, to negate, to wait, to collect, to
dissolve. Many hecatombs of human beings were sacrificed before these impulses learned to comprehend
their coexistence and to feel that they were all functions of one organizing force within one human
being, and even now the time seems remote when artistic energies and this is like his call for it when
artistic energies and the practical wisdom of life will join with scientific thinking to form a higher
organic system in relation to which scholars, physicians, artists, and legislators as we know them today
would look like partry paltry relics. In ancient times, so it's like all of those attributes all
all those qualities they they existed right, and uh but then they also then were interpreted into a form
that became science, right, and became knowledge, and and even science like science and knowledge as it exists
now it's still it doesn't have you know, and what he's pushing for you know it's it divorces
itself from artistic energies and the practical wisdom of life, right, like phronesis and aesthetics
are like different operations than the sort of uh you know sign what we're calling Wissenschaft here
you know, so um so that to me that gives you a sense. Now that doesn't mean science had to happen
either, right, like it necessarily right, and in other words those attributes could have not ever coalesced
it could have gone a different way, but then you could have had one other you know ingredient to
it and want to become something, yeah, become something different. But I mean it doesn't exist without
a history, like it doesn't exist without uh you know components that have come from come from
somewhere and serve different functions, right, like that's I mean that's the whole argument about
Christianity. Like Christianity it has it can do one kind of thing but it also does another kind of
like you know it Christianity takes certain types of story right and and hooks it to other kinds of
things so that it becomes uh life deprecating uh in in in the case of the religion but it also can be
life-affirming in the case of the guy Jesus, right, like that's in the like in the Antichrist stuff
well also just think like what would have happened to sort of like a you know a the Christian thread
you know let's let's keep sort of the Jesus guy and the sort of the background of Judaism
intact but now a subtract you know um Roman Empire and institution? Yeah, I think it is. I but I think
this mode that mode of thinking is very Hegelian. Yeah, like it just is like I think that that dimension
of the thinking is it resonates very very similarly. Well because I don't find it to be Hegelian because
it's not dualistic and it's not about negation or at most negation is is one of the many other sort
of factors at play. Well I agree with I agree with that, but I don't think it has to be dualistic in that
sense. I do think that when you're talking about like yeah I mean things disparately function one way
they get coordinated into a figure that becomes something else, that seems like that's like for
The formation, the formation of consciousness or something. Well, there's a version of Hegel that's
more of a monist, you know, where it's like negation or appropriation is the underlying engine of every
institution, every disposition, which I think you kind of get with the will. The will is the mechanism for
the church and for science. It's just how does it manifest, you know? I mean, the question is where
what's the function and what's the place of the negative, and I wasn't thinking of dual. Was I? I agree
with you. I was thinking in terms of, yeah, like the, that, like the dualism of the the production of the die
elective, right? Where, you know, the opposite is produced through the negation, and like, look, I can
see that to a... I can see negation as playing a role here, but it's just one role of many. It's not the
primary operation. So, for example, like in the science one that you were just talking about, like, different
things have to come together. Well, one of the things that have to come together has to be the the
pronunciation of of science calling itself science and negating aesthetics and and phronesis as an
operation. Yeah, we are not that right now. That's not sufficient for creating something called science.
That also has to be. It has to be one element, like that's one of the elements that has to congeal for
all of the other things, right? And, you know, at a certain point, at a certain point one might say
that, like, this thing that calls itself science by negating phronesis and aesthetics might eventually
be able to synthesize or call those things or become subsumed by those other things, and you might even
then say that for that new thing to exist as a thing, and if it cares about being a thing, it would
have to then negate something else, right? Yeah, because you're, you're right, because there is this sense in
which I, I see what you're saying because there is a sense in which for like in the passage we just read
for science to be formed it's not really rejecting aesthetics and pragmatism, it's just doing something
else, it's it's like, you know, his complaint is that we need to add that in, we need to make that a part of
the operation, but it's not like uh this the fact in that description, the founding of science is just like
this concatenation of these once negative attributes that when they found their place together in a
person, you know, became generative, right? Um, and productive, so they they weren't negative. The
the formation was like, no, this is just a new form of life and a new possibility for living, and uh, yeah,
and then we're still throw some more ingredients into, yeah, yeah, yeah, no, like it's not to say, yeah, way
more multiple, and again, like the function of the negative there can be, it doesn't have to be um
dialectically introduced, it can just be one more element, because let's be honest, we uh, um, science
or scientists or boy, you know, however it happens, but often gets um uh, negatively introduced. Like, it
is science because it is not x y or z. It's just, yeah, that's not the essential nature of science, and
that's not the only way of sort of thinking about it. It's just one thing that happens more frequently in
in this arena less frequently or not, but I mean just, but say like reduction or appropriation in the place
of negation. I mean generally speaking all science in order to taxonomize anything it's it's a movement
of reduction, right, of a multiplicity. So the engine I think would still be some version of negation even if
maybe it's not a Hegelian version. Like, to me, the will is negation, like, and and Nietzsche critiques the
will, right? I mean, he's not like full-throated endorsement of the will to power, obviously. I mean
that's what creates resentment on and all the bad or whatever the you know, the bad forms of life um
so I think I think negation is like is kind of both the engine of the will to power and of course
Nietzsche is trying to do something different, but I but I think it's all kind of there, right? I mean, I don't
know what I'm trying to. The only thing I would say is that multiplicity throws a huge it doesn't get
rid of negation it just reconfigures the place and value of negation in relationship to everything
else, right? It's sort of like saying negation is too simple, like negation and sublation are too simple.
Yeah, that's crazy thing to say because sublation is still something that I don't understand well I'm
not trying yeah I don't want to just but so like you can't swap out appropriation for negation, right?
because appropriation can be a lot of different things and appropriation can be an appropriation
through negation but that's not the only way it can has to happen. Yeah, because the appropriation can
suck it in and make it itself without creating any kind of distancing effect that that negation requires.
Well, I would say that I mean Hegel's negation is kind of synonymous with appropriation, I mean we
don't have to I don't want to I would say that Hegel's negation is an appropriation. I agree with that. It
is a kind of appropriation. I just don't think it's the only kind. Yeah, no, I don't want to conflate
Nietzsche and Hegel and just kind of like mash them together. This is very interesting to me because I
would like to parse that. I mean, we obviously will continue to, but it's, it's, it's nice to have that
question at least for me in the back of my head of, like, what are the ways in which if if Nietzsche
himself saw The Birth of Tragedy as a Hegelian book, um, he obviously doesn't see his later work as being
that, um, so so what does he see as the distinguishing features of the dynamic of we're saying multiplicity
appropriation will to power, um, that's that he sees as, I mean, he may be wrong and he may be a bad reader
of Hegel and all that shit is certainly possible, but you know, I don't think that's it. Yeah, no, for
sure. Well, I mean, first of all, Nietzsche, he doesn't mention Hegel all that much, so a lot of the critique
is just in his own theory. It's like that it's, it's laid out in the actual content of the text rather
than, like, sometimes it just it feels like Hegel is really being, oh, for sure, taken out. I mean, it's
yeah, yeah, but he's, he's rarely named explicitly, which is kind of interesting. I agree, I agree, oh
but it is also so that is that's a historical I mean because he does there's where does he talk
about at one point he's like it's it's a fine little schoolboy uh pedagogy, right? He's he's incredibly
dismissive of like, you know, that people were trained in and and I I don't even know what that means, like
like I don't know what the schoolboy I mean I do know that the you know that the notion of the
buildings ramon I mean the the uh right the spirit was was written as an educational program
and it failed miserably as that. Yeah, kids did not love the Phenomenology.
It wasn't a hit, but um but zero out of five stars. Yeah, yes, this book. I don't know what I don't know
what that actually means. Like what was actually being taught? What is Nietzsche making fun of there as
this sort of wrote schoolboy exercise of Hegelianism? I'm sure it's some version of, you know, the the
thesis into this is exactly where it's the kind of vulgar version of Hegel, but that's that that is a
version of Hegel that that's how it's like a step above a syllogism. It's like let's make the syllogism a
little more complex and this is what we'll teach kids, um, so yeah, I mean if that's the Hegel that
Nietzsche is running with for the most part then of course you'd want to not be that, right? You know,
like who would want to do that? Maybe it is that's just boring. I I just I just wish that there was some
smart philosophy guy or girl who would write that book, right? Like Hegel Hegel v Nietzsche yeah like
maybe someone has and yeah well to me like I I've written a little bit on the obviously in the in
the disc but to me the the conceptual where where Nietzsche diverges conceptually it's it's so um
like minute but complex where it's really hard to differentiate but he's clearly making some
shifts and not just not I'm not just talking about affirmation versus negation because you can you can
kind of systematize those where they seem to operate almost identically but to me the the most drastic
difference is the in the ethical we're in the push because Nietzsche is constantly searching for something
else and Hegel never does that. He goes like this is what we live in this is how the world works and
this is how it's always going to be whereas Nietzsche there's a there's a constant pull
and and push the whole thing is overcoming the human right right the whole right so the insistence
on an ethical transformation is to me the the biggest difference but then when you look at
to me it would be really difficult to write a full book just on the conceptual differences like you'd have
to get in the weeds to like you know where it wouldn't even be I'm not even sure how I think
you need i think you need to do that all right all right i'll try give it a go
so you